les élections italienne net recul de la
démocratie chrétienne stabilité du parti
communiste légère hausse des socialistes
et progression sensible des
néo-fascistes accident de car de
l'autoroute a66 hier matin le chauffeur
un culte et manifestation à poitiers de
riverains indignés par la mort d'un
enfant fauchés par un camion dans un
virage très dangereux sur ces affaires
la réflexion de paul le lit cette
centrale électrique dont une nucléaire
progressivement fermé par le dr d'ici la
fin 2009 185
enfin en tennis la défaite surprise de
connor sa wimbledon victoire de lendl
mcenroe et la khadra génère billie jean
king
mesdames messieurs bonsoir avant toute
chose la situation en corse depuis une
petite semaine en effet on assiste à un
regain de tension disparition du
militant nationaliste orsoni
manifestation mitraillage d'une caserne
de crs de bastia de crs blessés dont
l'un gravement tentative d'attentât
contre plusieurs gendarmerie dernière en
date celle de propriano ce matin les
observateurs voient là des réflexes de
bête blessée d'animaux traqué par les
chasseurs disait notre confrère du monde
mais le malaise est bien là et difficile
à dissiper en quelques jours
jean claude darmon une agression
gratuite une provocation politique lié
enlèvement de guy orsoni à son
assassinat probable on ne sait pas
encore le pourquoi de la tacc la nuit
dernière d'une caserne de crs dans la
banlieue de bastia un individu sortie
posément de sa voiture à 30 mètres de la
caserne a ouvert le feu avec un pistolet
mitrailleur sur la fenêtre éclairée du
poste de garde
une rafale 12 impact de crs s'écroule
l'un d'entre eux est blessé grièvement
l'autre ne doit la vie qu'à un briquet
sur lequel les projectiles se sont
écrasés à la hauteur du coeur je dois
vous avez reçu combien d'impact
trois impacts qui ont pénétré trois
rebelles ont pénétré et trois obus mais
j'aurai ta peau quand on sait ce qu'on a
en retour et en fusillade alors
un ver voter enfin c'est la tentation
est grande aujourd'hui pour les
nationalistes corses de lier tous les
événements de ces derniers jours le
commissaire broussard pense qu'il faut à
tout prix éviter l' amalgame
il ya des malfaiteurs qui se sont
trouvés être à cheval entre des
activités à caractère politique et
l'activité de droit commun mais le
mélange en intimant les deux on a eu
quand même quelques exemples ces
derniers temps voir par exemple battesti
qui comme et aider à la fois des
attentats qui se sont avérées être
revendiqué par le flnc et qui a commis
des hold-up pour son compte personnel
et puis nous avons également des gens
qui sont des gens très actifs au sein de
l'ex fait danser et qui je suis
absolument convaincu qu'ils sont ce sont
des purs ce sont des gens qui y croient
on en pense ce que l'on voudra mais ce
sont quand même des gens qui n'ont rien
à voir avec le banditisme
donc il ne faut pas mélanger ne faut pas
sur des surtout dire que si on arrête
tous les voyous de corse il n'y aura
plus de 2 des faits l'insee et
réciproquement si on arrête le flnc
il n'ira plus de voyons en corse il faut
faire la part des choses il est clair
maintenant que certains encore se
veulent entretenir un climat
d'insécurité et de peur une charge de
dynamite d'un kilo 500 a été découvert
ce matin sous l'appartement du
commandant de la brigade de gendarmerie
de propriano seul l'humidité l'empêcher
d'exploser le chauffeur du car accidenté
hier matin ni tri dans l'yonne sur
l'autoroute a6 a été inculpé aujourd'hui
d'homicides et de blessures
involontaires et défaut de maîtrise de
son véhicule
philippe brizard qui a été laissé en
liberté avait reconnu s'être assoupi je
vous rappelle que cinq britanniques sont
morts dans l'accident et 31 baissé
pendant ce temps près de poitiers
manifestation silencieuse lors des
obsèques d'un enfant tué par un camion
dans un virage dangereux maintes fois
dénoncée par les riverains
michel perron c'est la quasi totalité du
village de tourriers qui suivait ce
matin le cortège funèbre du petit franck
audigier huit ans tuée dans un accident
de la route
vendredi l'enfant se trouve avec sa mère
à l'intérieur d'une deux shows en
stationnement à proximité d'un double
virage particulièrement dangereux à
l'entrée du village
un camion fou surgi à grande vitesse
perd son contrôle et fauche la voiture
l'enfant est décapité ce pro et ça pour
être in broyer quant à la mère de franck
elle est toujours dans le coma ce double
virage de tourriers est un des points
noirs de la nationale 10 depuis de
nombreuses années la municipalité a
réclamé une déviation vers depuis le
coin à partir du mur qui a été remonté
plusieurs fois à la baille qu'on voit
encore des crépis ça a commencé là cette
maison qui était la propriété de ces
malheureux et qui viennent d'être
touchées la dont le fils vient de tuer a
déjà été touché une fois ou deux
puisqu'on voit les deux impacts la
maison du médecin
ici ils viendraient on a refait les on a
refait les volets fédéral est elle même
accroché la maison suivante a eu au
moins trois impacts avec les voler un
camion est rentré dans la dernière
fenêtre là également il rentrait là la
grand-mère qui couchent et blanc était
couverte de gravats et on voit ensuite
après son portail et 9 ainsi qu'une
moitié du mur parce que ça a été démolie
également est le pire que nous ayons eu
enfin par celui là c'est un camion qui
s'est couché
rentrant dans un camion qui venait en
face juste un petit peu plus bas il ya
eu également un tué et deux miraculés
puisqu'il était coincé dans la maison
que les enfants est sorti du banc pour
la déviation les pouvoirs publics disent
il n'y a pas de crédit quant à la mise
en place d'un feu rouge cette mesure
réduirait la fluidité de la circulation
de la nationale 10 oui aujourd'hui cette
manifestation hier cet accident sur
l'autoroute a6 la semaine dernière la
même chose sur l'autoroute du nord et
puis surtout il ya un an cette tragédie
à beaune autant de gros titres dans les
journaux qui s'inscrivent désormais de
manière indélébile dans la conscience de
chacun paul lefebvre fait patrick il ya
un an bonne il ya deux jours jouxte la
ville ce matin un terrier trois photos
atroces avec des gens qui pleurent et
qui sème une émotion d'autant plus
grande d'ailleurs que les médias sert la
radio la télé en quelques minutes touche
la france entière avec des flammes et
des cris à partir de là une réaction est
aussi une hypocrisie réaction elle est
profonde souvent instinctive c'est pas
vrai encore mais pourquoi dans notre
société que certains appels d'assistance
le besoin constant et d'éliminer tous
les risques de les rejeter de se
protéger d'assurer le demain peut-être
de trop oublier la vraie fatale
et celle que l'on ne peut prévoir ni
réglementés de rechercher à tout prix la
cause responsable c'est-à-dire au fonds
de se sécuriser quelqu'un c'est sûr a
commis la faute
quelqu'un mais pas soit et c'est là les
pros crise' depuis dix ans le nombre des
morts sur la route ne diminue pas douze
mille chaque année une petite ville de
français disparaît et 300000 sont
blessés imaginez nice tout entière à
l'hôpital mais qui tue qui blessent et
c'est moi c'est vous nous tous qui nous
prenons chacun pour le meilleur
conducteur mais qui doucement
tranquillement le coeur paisible avec le
sourire en dedans petit imprudents sur
pas vu pas pris
nous pardonnons un feu grillé une boîte
à 140 un coup de fatigue à trop bon
déjeuner enfin vous savez on sait puis
on recommence
tiens à les voir samedi que l'épée à
l'étranger maintenant avec une fois de
plus une tentative de nos voisins
italiens d'essayer de débrouiller
l'imbroglio politique qui sert de
système de gouvernement à ce pays depuis
la fin de la guerre dès ce soir les
consultations vont reprendre entre
politiciens pour savoir qui va diriger
le pays le résultat des élections qui
vient tout juste de tomber
officieusement les ne les aidera guerre
en gros il faudra prendre les mêmes et
recommencer cela dit victor moment on
assiste quand même un internaute
d'évolution notable
on peut dire que l'événement le plus
imprévus et le plus imprévisible de ces
élections c'est le fait que la
démocratie chrétienne et perdu près de
6% de ses voix on peut dire qu'au cours
des élections qui se sont succédé en
italie depuis la fin de la guerre jamais
aucun parti politique n'avait subi une
telle variation
bref la démocratie chrétienne fait son
score électoral le plus faible depuis 35
ans maintenant le parti communiste
italien
il n'a pratiquement rien perdu ni rien
gagné c'est assez étonnant puisque avant
les élections les sondages disaient que
le parti communiste alain était en perte
de vitesse
en tout cas le parti communiste italien
reste le deuxième parti politique en
italie après la démocratie chrétienne né
d'une seconde victoire parce qu'on voit
les chiffres qui ne sont pas toujours
très lisibles s'inscrit sur l'écran les
premiers chiffres sont donc ceux de 83
32 % pour la démocratie chrétienne et
ensuite 30% pour le parti communiste on
voit ensuite ce que donnent les
évolutions par rapport à 79
continuez dans victor sur le parti
socialiste peut-être oui le parti
socialiste puisque c'est le parti
socialiste qui a provoqué ces élections
anticipées
alors qu'est ce qu'ils espéraient le
parti socialiste gagner des voix
c'est disons à un demi succès puisque le
parti socialiste gagne 1,5 pour cent des
voix qu'est ce qui est important pour le
parti socialiste
est ce que c'était de gagner des voix ou
bien d'affaiblir la démocratie
chrétienne ci s'était affaibli la
démocratie chrétienne et bien ce n'est
plus un demi succès mais un succès tout
court
il y a une grosse surprise encore pour
ces élections c'est la victoire de deux
petits partis
il y à la victoire afin tout rôle tout à
fait relative du petit parti républicain
qui passe de 3 à 5 1% des voix pour
l'italie c'est beaucoup c'est même
énorme
mais surtout il y à cette grosse
surprise qui constitue que constitue le
succès du hem et si c'est à dire le
parti néo fasciste
le parti néo fasciste a gagné des voix
il passe de 5,3 à 7,1 pour cent alors on
pourrait dire qu'il y a en italie
actuellement une poussée vers la droite
je ne pense pas que ce soit le cas je
pense que les électeurs qui ont été
déçus par ce qu'on appelle en italie la
partitocratie c'est à dire le régime des
partis il est possible que ces électeurs
se soient portés donc vers le msi il est
aussi une chose qui est à souligner
c'est que le msi se prononce pour le
rétablissement de la peine de mort en
italie
alors dans ce climat d'insécurité qui
existe actuellement
on s'explique peut être mieux le succès
du parti néo fasciste
est ce que pour autant viktor l'italie
vous parlez plus gouvernable qui hier je
dirais que elle sera encore moins
gouvernable qu'avant puisque avant ces
élections de 1983 il y avait tout de
même une base politique une charnière
politique qui était le parti
démocrate-chrétien maintenant le parti
démocrate chrétien très affaibli il ya
aussi un autre élément c'est que la
seule coalition gouvernementale qui peut
rendre en italie c'est une coalition à
cinq parties alors vous imaginez bien
qu'une coalition gouvernementale à cinq
partis ça marche plutôt très mal et les
petits partis laïques c'est à dire par
exemple les parti socialiste le parti
républicain qui ont gagné quelques voix
au cours de ces élections vont devenir
beaucoup plus ambitieux
et ils vont rendre la tâche de la
démocratie chrétienne qui sera chargé
éventuellement de former le gouvernement
ils vont rendre cette tâche encore plus
difficile oui le tout sur fond de
terrorisme puisque il y a encore rien un
attentat est extrêmement grave à turin
oui il ya eu un attentat hier soir à
turin qui est assez étonnant puisque
tout de même cette campagne électorale
s'était déroulée dans un calme absolu
on a tué hier soir donc à turin vers
vers 3h15 le procureur général von au
catch cela était un attentat d'une
incroyable lâcheté puisque le procureur
général était en train de promener son
chien dans la rue sans évidemment aucune
escorte de policiers
on ne peut pas dire que bruno catch
s'occuper d'une affaire en particulier
mais disons que tous les dossiers qui
étaient traités à turin passés entre ses
mains
alors il faut peut-être rappeler qu'il
est actuellement à turin un procès
contre les terroristes des brigades
rouges et de prima linea
peut-être que cela explique cet attentat
qui a été revendiqué par les brigades
rouges
merci victor on vous retrouve à 23h donc
pour le résultat complètent ces
élections marquées je vous le rappelle
par un recul de la démocratie chrétienne
et par un progrès assez nets des
néo-fascistes moscou un sommet prévu
demain réunira dans la capitale
soviétique les chefs des sept partis
communistes est européen le général
daoud qui sera là pour la pologne
on n'en sait pas plus pour le moment
sauf qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une réunion
du pacte de varsovie
le maréchal ustinov le ministre
soviétique de la défense a lancé
aujourd'hui une nouvelle mise en garde à
l'occident à propos des dangers du
déploiement des euromissiles chili fin
de la grève déclenchée par le
commandement national des travailleurs
durée indéterminée avait-on dit jeudi
mais le mot d'ordre s'est soldée
finalement par un demi-échec le général
pinochet ne tolèrera pas de nouvelles
journées de protestation
tunisie un appel à l'entente avec la
syrie un appel de yasser arafat qui
venait de rencontrer le président
bourguiba et qui illustre bien la
volonté d'apaisement du chef de l'olp et
singulièrement affaiblie depuis trois
jours
yasser arafat a en effet proposé au
président assad au président syrien donc
de former un front uni contre israël et
d'oublier les rancunes cad la france
gravement préoccupé
et par les développements la situation à
vie tout à l'heure le quai d'orsay pour
contrer l'offensive de l'ex président
goukouni oueddei soutenu par la libye la
france enverra des munitions au
gouvernement d'hissène habré
voici maintenant des images du lancement
de soyouz t9 avec à son bord deux
cosmonautes un lancement qui prouve bien
que l'incident survenu il y a deux mois
au cours du vol de soyouz tma 8 n'était
pas très grave apparemment soyouz ses
neuf va maintenant rejoindre le train
spatial saliou death est inoccupé depuis
six mois
des images en tout cas retransmise est
extrêmement rapidement par l'urss
catastrophe aérienne de d'après midi en
allemagne de l'ouest au moins six morts
et huit blessés dans la collision entre
un mirage iii français un petit avion de
tourisme le chasseur s'est alors abîmé
sur une petite ville du sud ouest
allemand il a frôlé deux supermarchés et
a réussi à éviter une station d'essence
mais s'est finalement écrasé sur des
maisons d'habitation patrice pollet
c'est tout un quartier de bieber h en
allemagne de l'ouest qui a été détruit
par la chute d'un mirage iii de la base
aérienne de strasbourg
équipé de caméras deux mirage de
reconnaissance volé tôt ce matin en
direction de memmingen la collision
s'est produite avec un bimoteur de
tourisme est un des mirages qui volait
très exactement à la même altitude
l'avion français alors tombé comme une
torche sur le village le pilote rester
aux commandes jusqu'au dernier moment
invité deux supermarchés et une pompe à
essence pour venir s'écraser contre des
habitations
la collision était tellement violentes
que 7 à 2 km dans un bois qu'ont été
retrouvés les débris de l'avion de
tourisme le bilan de cet accident est
lourd sept morts dont les deux pilotes
et vie blessés c'est la cinquième
collision de ce genre survenue en
allemagne de l'ouest
depuis le 10 mai
politique dans la tente des déclarations
du chef de l'état demain matin en direct
sur europe 1 max gallo le porte parole
du gouvernement s'en est pris aux
responsables de l'opposition et à juger
leurs déclarations caractérisée par la
prétention l'amnésie et la cacophonie
réponse indirecte du rpr charles pasqua
tout à l'heure sur france inter il ne
peut y avoir de gouvernement dans un
pays démocratique sans le soutien
populaire
il peut arriver un moment où dans une
situation donnée
il vaut mieux revenir devant le peuple
et le consulter que laisser la loi hope
avait elle dit le responsable rdr
edf va fermer dix sept centrales d'ici
la fin 2009 185 17 centrales électriques
au charbon 5 au mazout est une nucléaire
des fermetures destiné à aligner la
production d'électricité sur la
consommation révisé en baisse
la france a donc peut-être été trop
ambitieuses en matière d'énergie
nucléaire mais maintenant c'est l'emploi
de plusieurs milliers de personnes qui
est menacé comme nous le montre bien
ce reportage de dix schwartz et de
claude sicard telle la belle au bois
dormant ce chantier va peut-être bientôt
s'endormir il a été piqué en effet par
une mauvaise fée qui s'appelle
stagnation économique et le point
charmant qui lui redonnerait vie
entendez par là l'expansion on ne le
voit pas venir avant plusieurs années
c'est lui et lui seul qui pourrait
inciter le gouvernement à relancer le
programme de construction de centrales
nucléaires d'ici là chez les industriels
on fera grise mine
la construction d'au moins deux tranches
par an en france est nécessaire pour
maintenir en état
l'outil industriel au dessous de ce
chiffre on aboutit à son démantèlement
ceux ci menacent l'emploi de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes sur un
total approximatif de 250 mines
de toutes les entreprises concernées les
firmes locales semblent les plus
pénalisées en matière d'emploi par je
dirais contacts que nous avons eus avec
le maître d'ouvragé est à dire le dr
une partie importante de la main
d'oeuvre utilisé sur le grand chantier
est d'origine locale
on estime même que l'été au montant de
50 % environ
on parle maintenant de ralentissement du
pôle nucléaire alors quelles
conséquences raté la voir pour vous et
bien si la politique d'accueil du grand
chantier était une certitude la
politique d'après chantier ce n'est plus
un espoir dans l'espoir quand même
lorsque le chantier de palluel sera
terminé qu'est ce que vous avez fait ce
qu il nous regarde et vous mobilisant un
autre nous sentir mal or le chômage
pour l'instant on ne savait pas où vous
irez annoncé par avance
certaines entreprises sont restées
prudentes elles n'ont pas choisi de tout
miser sur le nucléaire et moi le
fabricant de ces grilles de protection
les ouvriers qui l'avait embauché pour
le chantier de palluel il les gardera il
tient à demeurer un artisan un
ferronnier d'art
certaines entreprises se sont beaucoup
développées en poursuivre les chantiers
de du nucléaire ça c'est un petit peu ce
qui est à craindre maintenant c'est ce
ralentissement ça va poser de sérieux
problèmes pour ces entreprises
donc j'ai grillé de leur part qu'elles
ont montré deux visages de la prévision
est un petit peu d'appels de modestine
l'état et edf sont de toute façon
contraints de prendre en compte les
problèmes d'activité qui vont se poser
aux entreprises qui construisent elle
est centrale dans une première période
il pourrait être procédé à un étalement
dans le temps des travaux déjà engagés
mais surtout il pourrait décider de
lancer des grandes opérations
d'équipement comme des travaux routiers
ou la mise en place de réseaux de
chaleur ce qui assurerait au moins du
travail aux entreprises de génie civil
pour les autres celles qui sont
directement impliqués dans le nucléaire
ou l'électricité
il sera certainement plus difficile de
les reconvertir
sous prétexte de sauvegarder l'emploi
on imagine mal qu'il faille continuer à
fabriquer des produits devenus
provisoirement inutile le président de
la fédération du bâtiment à l'elysée
chez le chef de l'état il n'est pas
possible d'avoir un brin d'optimisme a
dit jacques danon qui parle de
l'effondrement de son secteur nouveau
repli du dollar aujourd'hui à paris
cette france 57 3 centimes de moins que
vendredi
le franc français regagnent un petit peu
de terre l'ouverture du congrès du
syndicat national des instituteurs à
bordeaux deux cent soixante mille
adhérents pour ce syndicat est un
certain nombre d'inquiétudes et
d'impatiences beaucoup plus qu il y a
deux ans lors du dernier contre lorraine
cusin indiscutablement à bordeaux le ton
se durcit bien sûr dit ces enseignants
il ya beaucoup de réflexions en cours au
ministère mais peut encore de
perspectives claires ni de programmes
éducatifs d'ensemble les militants
s'impatiente notamment sur la question
de la laïcité alors devant ce
mécontentement de la base les dirigeants
du sc ni peuvent définir une action
syndicale original face à un gouvernent
manquent ils ont appelé de leurs voeux
la grande affaire de ces quatre journées
ça va être effectivement de trouver la
voie étroite entre deux pièges le piège
de la courroie de transmission parce que
le gouvernement a aujourd'hui
effectivement des objectifs qui sont
très proches dénoncent tous bien le
prêtre quand on les fatigue maison pas
nous faisons en sorte qu'ils adoptent et
l'autre piège qui est celui du
corporatisme
alors pour nous nous allons rechercher
je pense qu'on peut le trouver cela
comment l'organisation syndicale de
masse peut agir
je veux dire en toute indépendance je
crois que la question clé aujourd'hui
c'est effectivement l'indépendance du
syndicat vis-à-vis du pouvoir
et c'est d'autant plus difficile que
effectivement le pouvoir et gauche je
veux pas cacher cette réalité je dirais
dans une phrase peut être un petit peu
trop sibylline mais que nous
développerons en aucun cas un syndicat
ne peut s'identifier un parti laisser ni
néanmoins s'est félicité d'une lettre
d'alain savary lui confirmant que la
réforme des collèges seraient
entreprises à la rentrée 84 une
confirmation par charles hernu les
confirmations officielles cette fois de
ce qui se chuchotait puis d'un an chez
les militaires la france a bien
expérimenter la bombe à neutrons en août
dernier un mur au roi si le président
mitterrand décidé de la construction de
cette arme a dit le ministre de la
défense aux journalistes du spiegel
eh bien nous pourrions immédiatement la
réaliser nouvelles arrestations dans la
sphère des pots-de-vin de marseille
après celle d'un ancien conseiller
municipal socialiste robert ça fera ni
et son suppléant
cette fois c'est l'un des dirigeants de
la somme a cédé à l'entreprise
spécialisée dans l'enlèvement des
ordures ménagères et des déchets
industriels qui a été inculpé et écroué
à la prison de versailles suite de notre
sondage sur les français et les vacances
réalisé avec le club de madère le point
cette fois après les fantasmes le sport
les français aiment toujours autant se
reposer mais apparemment
incontestablement l'activité physique
après une part prépondérante puisque 83%
des moins de 20 ans veulent en profiter
pour se dépenser et 57 % des plus de 50
ans entre les deux l'âge de nos deux
reporters jean jacques dufour et bruno
carette qui ont constaté l'influencé
croissante des activités sportives dans
les programmes proposés partout en
france
aux vacanciers
cette image d'un français en vacances
sur un relaxe en train de lire un
bouquin s'est terminée aujourd'hui en
1983 voilà sur pour les pendulaires en
vacances
du sport et encore du sport après les
vacances tarzan sera de retour en ville
cette revendication au droit à la fibre
musculaire amène les industriels des
loisirs de l'hôtellerie à s'affronter
sur le terrain des animations sportives
des stages en tout genre à vide
d'activité corporelle nos compatriotes
veulent courir sus et s'éclater
physiquement fini le temps des pensions
de famille style transat le matelas
multi spire la bonne table c'est à la
portée de beaucoup d'hôtels et de plus
en plus hôtellerie moderne s'oriente
vers un produit complet basé sur le
principe de la remise en forme donc de
la santé et le sport participe à cette
famille en fond et il faut de plus en
plus offrir à notre clientèle des
produits complexes
le sondage le point n 2 indique donc
jusqu'à 40 ans plus de 60% des français
veulent faire du sport pendant leurs
vacances jean michel lavergne en stage
de tennis ici à evian est l'un d'entre
eux son emploi du temps et simple du
sport du sport et encore du sport cies
coup de vacances faux j'en profite t
offert le sport pour remettre en forme
pour
améliorer les performances puisque avec
une heure ou deux par semaine toute
l'année c'est pas suffisant
alors là on est là pour une semaine on y
va enfin lyon et que le même reportage
il ya 20 ans j'aurais trouvé les gens
qui m'aurait dit moi je passe ma journée
sur la plage sur une chaise longue à
jouer aux boules
est ce que je faisais ya 20 ans avec mes
parents je suis pas les générations
changer et oui aujourd'hui cultivé son
corps est devenu une exigence et c'est
pourquoi dans l'hôtellerie haut de gamme
on voit se multiplier les installations
permettant des cures biologiques
diététiques et autres fini le pintadeau
aux choux à la carte le bain
bouillonnant l'extrait d'algues le
bronzage uv
si le tourisme social n'a pas les moyens
d'offrir ce genre de prestation à ses
clients il joue néanmoins la carte du
sport à fond lui aussi ainsi à balaruc
sur l'étang de thau dans un village de
tourisme et travail
alors ici c'est la planche à voile
ailleurs ça sera le tennis a commencé le
tennis sur d'autres centres ça va être
autres activités comme les activités de
montagne mais nous avons senti ce besoin
de la part de nos adhérents et je pense
que nous essayons au maximum de nos
possibilités d'y répondre
elle enseigne à bas la rue parfois ça se
passe très bien ça se passe si bien qu
yvette conti retraité de la manufacture
des tabacs de riom a décidé de se mettre
devant nous à la planche à voile
il y aura beaucoup décès de planche à
voile
champion des gants une trentaine
d'années d'ailleurs le cri de ralliement
des vacanciers de retour en septembre
moi tarzan toi jane et si vous vous
entraînez bien vous pourrez approcher la
condition fissiles et bien physique
pardon de l'exceptionnel billie jean
king 40 ans cette année qui s'est
qualifié pour les quarts de finale du
tournoi de wimbledon en éliminant
l'australienne tonnes belle tête de
série numéro sept en deux manches billie
jean king a emporté six fois le titre à
wimbledon
chez les hommes la victoire de lendl de
mcenroe 7-5 7-6 7 6-2 sandmeier de tim
mayotte de carl lewis aux dépens du
regretté nigérian aux 10 hors de taner
de purcell face à gottfried et puis
surtout la surprise la défaite de connor
ses limites par le sud africain que
rennes
roger zabel on a beau s'appeler jimmy
connors être le numéro un mondial avoir
gagné plus de 3 milliards 200 millions
de centimes la saison dernière après
avoir remporté sept tournois à disputer
quatre finales et quatre demi finales
on a beau être le tenant du titre à
wimbledon le joueur préféré des
britanniques et pas seulement des
britanniques ont d'abord rencontré un
sud africain kevin curel assez peu
connue numéro 15 mondial seulement on a
beau remporter le deuxième set après
avoir perdu le premier et ça va être le
cas
voilà mon cher et il dit mais l'inter a
finement oui eh bien disons que le temps
est en train de changer
mais tout doucement et vous allez savoir
pourquoi en tout cas les la zone
orageuse s'éloigne vers le sud-est et
quand on regarde notre photo satellite
ce n'est peut-être pas évident mais vous
voyez l'anticyclone des açores ici en
train de gonfler progressivement et ben
il va gagner sur notre pays met en avant
en avant de cette zone il y aura donc
une première ronde de nuages qui a passé
sur la france demain et puis ici plus
haut ces nuages là eh bien ils
arriveront seulement jeudi et après on
peut espérer donc un temps qui va
s'améliorer pour demain c'est assez
simple attention il y aura des
brouillards à peu près partout mais
encore donc 1 résidus orageux sur le sud
est de la france mais qui s'illuminera
assez rapidement dans la matinée comme
les brouillards donc partout en soirée
il y aura des orages des alpes au massif
central qui se déclencheront en fin
d'après-midi en début de soirée ailleurs
c'est un temps donc variable dans
l'après midi avec des zones d'éclaircies
plus marquée au sud de la loire connor
enfin ce sera un temps relativement
agréable avec toutefois des ventes du
nord ce qui fait que les températures
sont encore un peu en baisse par rapport
à hier vous voyez en moyenne 18 à 21
degrés dans la moitié nord et 22 25 28
degrés même dans la moitié sud donc des
températures un petit peu basses pour la
fête des irene est un
un seuil qui s'élèvera 5h51 pour se
coucher à 21h56 et comment par l'horaire
à 23h et avec l'eau demain 12h45 daniel
bilalian et à 20 heures j'aurai le
plaisir de vous retrouver mais nous
allons nous quitter en chansons puisque
demain au palais des sports il va y
avoir une soirée exceptionnelle avec
eddy mitchell michel jonasz et véronique
sanson qui pour la circonstance ont
accepté d'interpréter une chanson à
trois une chanson rock
bonsoir avis
c'est pas
il va
non
un plan
m
à